i'm naperville police chief jason aries
the information audio and video you're
about to see are intended to provide
details as we currently understand them
of an officer-involved shooting that
occurred around 11 am on june 3rd 2022
this video may contain graphic images
that could be disturbing to some people
viewer discretion is advised this
incident occurred on northbound bond
street just north of the intersection
with mcdowell road on the northwest side
of naperville a naperville police
officer was conducting a traffic stop
when approximately 12 minutes into the
stop an uninvolved vehicle pulls up next
to the vehicle the officer has pulled
over
a man quickly exits the vehicle and
immediately charges at the officer with
a hatchet in his hand
in the videos that follow you'll see
that the officer discharges his firearm
striking the subject and then holds the
suspect at gunpoint until backup can
arrive to secure him both the officers
body worn and in-car cameras were
recording during the june 3rd incident
again viewer discretion is advised
[Applause]
all right i think it's a good picture to
send it to me
i just been attacked i just shots fired
shots fired
any loss of life is tragic and our
thoughts are with the family of the
deceased
i am extremely grateful however that
neither our officer nor any bystanders
were injured or killed as a result of
this incident
as you saw this scene went quickly from
a traffic stop for a minor violation to
an attack on a police officer by an
uninvolved party demonstrating just how
dangerous the job of a police officer is